hello everyone and welcome to another
incredible game from this match that
just keeps on delivering this is a round
seven or game seven of the uh of the
match game three of the of the second
day yanni pumici has the white pieces
and he now has to win to bounce back as
magnus won that crazy game six that
we've just seen where nipple sacrificed
slash blunder the piece uh and in the
end it was all for nothing so let's see
what happens in this one he has the
white pieces and now we will again have
the sicilian but now a real open
fighting sicilian so here e4
we have c5 magnus goes for the sicilian
defense knight f3 e6 uh and striking in
the center with the d4 like you always
should we have c captures on the four
knight captures and knight to c6 now
going for the taiman of variation knight
to c3 and queen to c7 uh the bastard
code line of the taimanov bishop to e3
and now a6 taking away the b5 square
from nepal's pieces and now
there are of course many moves you can
play here but nepo was for the
very very popular g4 and by very popular
i don't mean it's been played a lot it's
just been popular lately so here knight
capture on d4 this is a well-known line
so both of them of course know it very
well uh queen captures on d4 now b5
preparing to fiance to the light square
bishop bring the rook to c8 and so on so
here we have queen side castles not
worrying about anything that could
happen uh because this is a very very
crazy line bishop to b7
and now comes king to b1 and
interestingly the position has already
been played by both magnus and nipple
not against each other uh for example
magnus had it uh in uh
this year's tata steel tournament
against nils grandely who's gonna they
always played f3 here after magnus
played bishop to b7 uh that game ended
in a draw if you remember but here we
have king to b1 and this follows a
couple of other very very interesting
games we have knight to f6 and only now
f3 uh in the ftx crypto cup in 2021 uh
caruana uh uh had this against nepal
rather nipple had this against caron and
apple played the g5 here but for this
game nepo doesn't listen to his own
advice rather he goes for f3 and f3 is
actually what anand played against
jordan van feresta in this year's tata
steel tournament that he won in last
year's uh
uh not at a stealing last year's grant
just too rapid that he won so that's the
game that we will be following rook to
c8 only now g5 knights to h5 and queen
to d2s uh b4 can come at any point if
the knight moves you want something to
defend this c2 pawn so queen to d2
and now bishop to e7 uh interestingly as
both of them are very familiar with this
position the engine really likes bishop
to b4 here but uh obviously
it's not something that you'd enjoy
playing um
as it wasn't played in this game or in
the game on and versus fun forest so
here we have bishop to e7 bishop to h3
now and now finally b4 we have knight to
e2 now comes d5 striking in the center
uh interestingly all had all of this has
been played before uh bishop to g for
challenging the knight and now g6 and
finally
we reached a position where anand played
bishop to d4 he attacked the rook on h8
and he was uh able to win that game very
nicely against the iron vampires but
here we have bishop captures on h5
and this is now an original position
this is a completely new game so let's
see how magnus plays this with g
captures on h5 now comes knight to f4
planning knight captures on h5 and
bringing the knight over to f6 where it
will either remain a magnificent steed
or black will have to capture it and
then we will have advanced tarpon all
the way to f6 so here d captures an e4
knight captures on h5 and now e captures
on f3 getting a protected pass pawn on
f3 if the pawn moves we will also be
attacking the rook on h1 so it looks
like um
like an incredible position and uh it's
time for nepot to seize the initiative
with knight to f6 check
but nipple doesn't play it i we will
show it because it's very interesting
you have to capture otherwise you just
allow the knight to remain a monster
here uh and well you can't go to d8 with
the king you can go to f8 but that's
just a very very sad
so what you would have to do is captures
captures and now uh for example after
bishop to e4 going after the c2 pawn you
have to play king to a1 this is how
white gets uh
incredible advantage because now there's
really nothing you can do here you can't
move the queen otherwise queen is coming
to d7 it's just a much much better
position for white uh most likely a
winning one uh but nipple did not spot
this he played bishop to f4 he attacked
the queen here but magnus very happily
uh takes this opportunity to offer a
queen trade with queen to d8 nepal of
course declines the trade and now as the
rook is attacking the queen we have
bishop to d5 closing the d file and now
uh and finally never plays knight to f6
with check and the position is still
very very good for white but you have to
play b3 and it's a it's a position that
uh
it it's hard to
find such a move no no one would really
play this
in a classical game of course once you
calculate everything out and you realize
that knight to f6 check doesn't really
bring all that much you will you know go
through the moves and you will find b3
however here for a rapid game knight to
f6 check was played with bishop captures
g captures and now magnus spots the idea
and he immediately plays it rook the g8
queen the a5 was also very nice as the
aa2 pawn is weak but rook the g8 also
gets the job done
and now nipple needs to defend there are
well there's pretty much only one way to
hold this and that is rook to d2 for a
certain reason i will not say why uh as
i will spoil the pause the video moment
but uh here nipple played rook h to e1
which is very nice uh if the queen moves
for example you can play rook captures
on d5 as the the 6.8 spin you could do
that without the rook anyone but it's
just uh much nicer to have it however he
completely blunders uh the idea behind
carlson's last move so feel free to
pause the video and win the game for
magnus while not only the game ended the
match while i give you a couple of
seconds
so for those of you who are able to do
it congratulations on becoming the
champion of the air things masters or of
the first event of the melt world
champions chester and for those of you
who just want to enjoy the show uh it is
of course rook to g2 and how do you now
prevent the rook captures on c2 well
there's just not a lot you can do here
if you play rook to c1 then we play
queen captures on f6 and of course
there's not all that much you can do
here uh everything is just terrible the
queen can come to f5 you can put more
pressure here on the c2 pawn if if the
bishop moves if the queen moves you can
pick up the bishop if the bishop moves
you can play f2 so pretty much every
movie is winning here for black so
nipple tries a different idea he goes
for the tactical queen to a7 not saying
okay if you play something weird uh
let's say you you go after the spawn i'm
going to play rook captures on d5 and
now it's an instant draw you can't
capture with opponent you can't capture
with the queen because queen to e7 will
be checkmate uh and there's not all that
much you can do other than rook captures
through captures rook checks checks
checks your checks and we will probably
see a perpetual here so of course the
magnus figures this out he plays queen
to d7 doesn't allow this offers a queen
trade nipple has to go back and now only
now rook c captures on c2 and now how do
you defend this well it's very very
difficult bishop to c1 is played
covering the square
but now okay queen to a4 is always an
idea like we mentioned going after that
a2 pawn but here magnus goes for the
quickest kill possible and that is rook
captures on c1 uh king captures on c1 if
you play uh rook captures on c1 which
seems like a more natural move then
bishop captures an a2 is just game over
king captures queen to d4 white loses a
queen and you are getting checkmated
very quickly so instead king captures on
c1 is played but now queen to c6 with
check and what do you play now king to
b1 now comes queen to a4 threatening
here queen captures an a2 and
interestingly both a3 and b3 lose very
quickly if a3 just queen to c to check
king a1 now queen b3 going for checkmate
and uh if white tries this queen
captures and e5 idea because the e6 pawn
is pinned we just checkmate with queen
captures on b2 and another thing uh if
b3 is played instead then we just play
queen captures on a2 as the rook is here
let's not forget about the rook as i
know some of you have king c1 queen cap
queen at the c2 will be checkmate so
after queen to a4 nipple player rook to
d2 he has to try something otherwise
it's match over but now magnus just
played bishop capture 72 with check and
he was in this position on move 30 that
magnus carlsen won not the game
but also the entire event and the ian
ponchi resigned the game
uh so here you resign uh if you go king
to a1 then it's a very nice checkmate
with bishop to b3 check king has to go
to b1 queen 82 kings c1 and of course
queen to a1 will be checkmate and if you
play king to c1 instead then it's a very
nice queen to c6 check interestingly
this is the only winning line queen to
c6 check came to d1 and now bishop to b3
with check and now there is only one way
to block this you have to play rook c2
and now queen cactus and c2 will be
checkmate so of course ian knows all of
this and after bishop
a2 check he resigned the game and magnus
wins the entire thing interestingly
again uh everything uh i i mean nipple
had uh nipple had great chances in the
match he was really playing incredible
chess and magnus was uh
really trying to survive at some points
in the match uh but again it's this uh
crucial game six of the match that
always seems to be a turning point uh
in in every match maybe it's a
psychological thing maybe it's just the
maybe it's just you know you've already
played five of them so let's let's uh
uh it's hard to say uh but yeah after
winning game six uh never probably went
into game seven uh thinking about what
happened in game six and then it was a
really really quick collapse uh just 30
moves uh against the sicilian and nepo
is pretty much an expert in dismantling
a sicilian defense but magnus is of
course expert at playing the sicilian
defense uh so yeah that's the game hope
you guys enjoyed it and this very short
coverage of the earthings masters um uh
we'll see we'll see what happens uh uh
next uh i would like to thank cypher
kicks leo joel bourne james o'toole john
cousins and nikita nicolas for your
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot i really appreciate it as usual you
can check two of my previous videos here
thank you for watching and i will see
you soon continuing uh to check up on
your wonderful suggestions uh and
whatever else happens in the chess world
so thank you all i will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day